with the reveal of the PS 5 Joule sense
controller and all its fancy new bells
and whistles let's take a look back at
the history and evolution of the
PlayStation controller Before we jump
into the nitty-gritty of Sony's flagship
controller it's worth mentioning just
how the Sony Playstation came to be
originally meant to bolster the existing
SNES Sony partnered with Nintendo to
develop a cartridge disk hybrid console
dubbed the Nintendo PlayStation however
after some legal disputes Nintendo
pulled inaudible and partnered with
Philips a Sony competitor leaving Sony's
200 prototype consoles with nowhere to
go luckily for us instead of giving up
on the project
Sony quickly got over the breakup and
eventually released its own console the
PlayStation
[Music]
after circulating around a couple of
different prototypes Sony felt their
controllers resembled to the SNES
controller a little bit too much and
needed to find a way to better
differentiate itself from its former
partner enter the digital controller the
original PlayStation controller
possessed two sets of shoulder buttons
and a shape that had actual handles for
players to hold on to the distinct
design and button layout would
eventually become one of the most
recognizable aspects of the PlayStation
brand with even the triangle square
circle and cross buttons being cemented
as the consoles iconic symbols with
Playstation games making significant
strides in the still new 3d space Sony
would eventually release an enhanced
controller that allowed for more
sophisticated control along with longer
shoulder buttons the dual analog
controller was released with two analog
sticks and a slightly larger shape
compared to its predecessor giving
players a greater range of movement and
precision than ever before
while the introduction of analog sticks
was overall a welcomed addition the use
of it over the traditional d-pad was
still a relatively new idea so much so
that Sony even added an analogue button
in the center of the controller giving
players the option of turning them on
and off the Dual Shock controller
featuring twin analog sticks and haptic
feedback or rumble technology was a
significant upgrade for PlayStation
devices with analogue support on the
rise popular games like Metal Gear Solid
also took advantage of the new rumble
feature by making clever use of the
function during some of the game's most
iconic moments
[Music]
like the old saying goes if it ain't
broke don't fix it
the same could be said for the DualShock
to controller on the outside the
PlayStation 2 s Jill shuck was mostly a
minor upgrade from its ps1 predecessor
with the exception of an old black
finish to accompany its consoles look
beneath the surface however the ps2
controller was lighter and more
functional than that of the original
Jill shock the most noticeable upgrade
was the precious sensitive inputs for
all face and shoulder buttons creating
new ways for gamers to interact with
them games such as Gran Turismo 3 a
speck took advantage of the new feature
as your cars acceleration would greatly
depend on how much pressure you applied
on the buttons having this kind of
real-time feedback expanded the
possibilities of how players could
experience the type of games they love
to play debuting at e3 2005 the
PlayStation 3 was positioned as an
all-in-one home entertainment system
giving consumers access to the then-new
blu-ray disc formats to better utilize
this all-in-one device Sony presented
for the first time a dedicated home
button it was also the first time that
an official PlayStation controller was
completely wireless allowing you to
charge its internal batteries via USB
while these features were undoubtedly
impressive many people were distracted
by its unorthodox design the new design
was intended to reflect the new and more
modern approach of the ps3 but the
overall negative feedback prompted Sony
to go back to the drawing board making
the sixaxis more in line with
controllers that came before it in the
wake of a 2004 patent infringement case
from haptic feedback developer immersion
the ps3 launched - the controller that
lacked Rumble support while the case
made its way through court Sony put more
focus on the devices motion control
capabilities the sixaxis motion control
functionality was a big selling point
for the controller with big games like
Warhawk and lair leaning heavily on the
new movement style however in the years
following its release motion controls
would eventually become a minor feature
for most gamers Sony would eventually
settle the patents infringement case
with immersion and then introduced the
DualShock 3 bringing back the heavily
missed Rumble support
going back to the DualShock name the
ps3s DualShock 3 was a standard 6 access
controller with added vibration feedback
one of the first big games to utilize
the DualShock 3 z' rumble feature was
Metal Gear Solid 4 guns of the Patriots
and much like how the original Metal
Gear Solid broke the fourth wall to
acknowledge the Joe shock mgs4 also
included some moments where it singled
out the controller even poking fun at
how the sixaxis didn't have haptic
feedback
[Applause]
the PlayStation 4's Dualshock 4 was a
big step forward for the controller at
first glance it largely retained the
same distinctive shape and set of
features that previous controllers had
but it also introduced a bunch of new
upgrades that leaned further into online
gaming and entertainment effectively
doing away with the traditional start
and select buttons the new controller
added an options button as well as a
dedicated share button which allowed
gamers to share their favorite stills
and clips immediately on social media
the l2 and r2 buttons also saw an
upgrade which moved away from the flat
design from previous generations to a
more curved and trigger like shape
making them more comfortable to use
during action-oriented games with a new
light bar that made the top plate of the
controller glow in different colors the
Dual Shock 4 also added a touch pad on
the front center of the device which was
commonly used as a way to access menus
and other functions other add-ons
included a small speaker just below the
touchpad that would project in-game
sounds as well as a 3.5 millimeter audio
jack which allowed players to plug in
their preferred headsets in a later
update the DualShock 4 added a visible
light strip at the top of the touchpad
and the ability to use the controller as
a dedicated wired controller via USB
which wasn't possible with previous
models compared to other consoles the
playstation controller has been one of
the more visually consistent devices
giving it an iconic presence over the
last 26 years and while the dual sense
has most of the DualShock for
functionality it also boasts a handful
of new features like a USB type-c port
built-in mic a mysterious create button
in place of the share button and a
completely out of left field two-tone
design another feature that has the
gaming community intrigued is the
introduction of adaptive triggers an
advanced haptic feedback like pulling a
string on a bow or shooting a large gun
this new feature can potentially
replicate the feeling of tension and
force giving players a distinctive
real-time response during gameplay which
is your favorite PlayStation controller
and are you excited to try out the dual
sense let us know in the comment section
down below and stay tuned to game spot
for all ps5 coverage
[Music]
[Music]